hello i'm nichola cochran and i'm going
to play last time i on the kelly
clarkson show
the last time i was star struck was when
i met
one of the members of monty python
michael palin
we were at an award ceremony and i
didn't realize he was going to be there
and then i looked and he was like
two foot away from me and i just started
falling crying i had never been
truly starstruck before then but that
was an absolute disaster because i just
couldn't stop i loved him so much
oh the last time i had an awkward
audition this wasn't the last one this
is quite a long time ago but
it was an audition where you were meant
to be able to speak fluent irish
and i thought i could wing it turns out
don't try and wing speaking
another language because it it's just
don't do it trust me
last time i texted a bridgeton co-star
oh gosh
i send claudia jesse who plays eloise i
send her a lot of memes and stuff
because she doesn't
use social media so i'll send her uh
penelope eloise or pinellis as people
like to say fan art and things like that
we text each other a lot of silly things
we have a similar sense of humor so yeah
[Music]
last time i giggled myself oh gosh
it's because well i sometimes google
myself because my mom is in her 70s and
she's got a smartphone
and she doesn't understand algorithms so
things
articles will come up about me and she
said why where did that thing come from
that thing
on the internet now it's gone and i said
what is it she said
you were talking about a thing so i'll
google myself in order to find out what
she is talking about and what she's
found on the internet
last time i hugged an animal oh this
makes me really sad actually it would
have been on the set of bridgeton
there were two puppies in the makeup
trailer there was yuri and teddy
and teddy when we wrapped filming was
still this tiny little
i think he's like a cabochon or
something very tiny and fluffy
and he used to sit on your knee when you
were getting your makeup done and like
fall asleep but it was so cute so that
was like february 2020
far too long ago
the last time i shared a brigitte and
meme was somebody on twitter
who said my wife was watching bridgeton
or as i like to call it
ride and prejudice which i thought was
absolutely genius
and i'm gonna think of it as that in my
mind from now on
the last time i cried during a tv show
it was
was at pose post season two just like
rips your heart out of your body and
that whole cast are just so wonderful
and they tell that story so truthfully
so if i ever want a good cry i can just
stick that straight on and i know it'll
just be blubbing
[Music]
the last time i got great advice from a
bridgeton co-star
i think it's been quite a wild journey
for all of us
because you know the show has reached so
many people and so many people love it
but i think
speaking to johnny bailey and phoebe
denver
we're all sort of saying let's just take
this in and let's support one another so
maybe it's not so much advice but just
knowing that
we're gonna try and enjoy this and you
know it's a lot of craziness but i think
at the end of the day we just want to
come together and make a good show that
people love and that's
a really lovely thing
last time i gave someone a compliment i
would say
was my best friend maeve she has just
started she's working as an occupational
therapist and i was just very proud of
her and i said you know
you've achieved so much and love what
you're doing and i love you we should
give more compliments to the people we
love
you know life is short compliment people
the last time i received a compliment oh
my mom
complimented my hair today but i think
it's partly because we now have the same
haircut and she's very happy about that
and she said do you love your new hair
it's lovely isn't it
the last time i laughed so hard i cried
was actually this weekend it was my
birthday
and my friends hosted a zoom birthday
quiz in which they all dressed up as me
um from various different parts of my
life and parts that i've played and it
was just
ridiculous they had different rounds
like iconic tiny blondes
and there was a rupaul's drag race round
just because i love drag race but i
laughed
very very much that weekend it was great
the last time i had a paranormal
encounter i don't know if this counts
but it's funny because sometimes before
bed i'll read like
freaky stories or ghost stories they're
like about people disappearing and in
the beginning i'm like
super brave and i'm like this is all
rubbish and then the more i read the
more i get terrified and i can't like
stick my foot out
because i'm totally convinced that
someone's gonna like grab it out of my
bed so i'm not sure if that counts but
i definitely psyched myself up to think
it
[Music]
the last time i tripped in public i
actually
this has just made me remember that at
the bridgeton
was it the christmas party or the wrap
party some party where all the cast and
crew were there
we were in a place called shoreditch
house and it has these stairs that they
were quite dark and hard to see and
everyone fell down them
so it became like a thing that someone
would fall and we'd all go way but i
fell down
that night in front of a lot of people
when we were allowed to be around other
humans
oh the last time i was mistaken for
another celebrity even though i wouldn't
call myself a celebrity
someone thought i was florence pew and
told me i was very good at little women
but you know she was nominated for an
oscar for that and she's fantastic so i
will take that any day of the week
thank you for watching me play last time
i i've been nicola cochle and now go
watch bridgeton
followed by the kelly clarkson show
followed by bridgeton etc etc etc
bye
[Music]
you